so let's talk about yesterday yesterday
you guys came into town we uh i shot all
day
and we took scooters
and we went to a restaurant what do you
think
loved it it's called low wood so good
it's in tulsa can you guys believe i'd
never been on a scooter before oh you
told us for three hours well i thought
you guys were for sure gonna leave me
because that's what bobby does and guess
what he left me well
how do you go slower
i don't know what you're about to say
i'm going to get in trouble for that but
you're going to get in trouble you're
getting in trouble i'll get the one yeah
yeah how can you go slow on those
scooters like it's
you either punch it all the way you must
not know me you must not know how i rode
those brakes for a whole mile oh you
were holding the break down the whole
time that's more dangerous because your
hand is doing two things that you're
more likely to crash if you hold both
things like you got to hold the grip
hard and then just goose it guess what
george
you guys did a poor job at explaining
how to safely do that that's not true at
all
i'm on george's time
side
that's absolutely not true okay number
one you know what gilbert said though
what did gilbert say
on our way back from low wood the
restaurant which was delicious where we
had ice cream over salad and it blew my
fridge i blew my mind blue cheese ice
cream on greens yeah and walnuts and
pecans or something it was really really
good
jalapenos really good salad great place
if you're ever in tulsa so freaking save
money though save money for it yes yes
and we're going to tonight also um bull
in the alley
yes the little
i just want to let you know
we'll we'll talk about later but you
know yeah prepare yourself what did i
say after what i say what i say um
so uh after dinner i was experiencing
some digestion issues so i had diarrhea
all night massive all night yeah all
night it happens a lot to me i have
colitis but then i choose to just eat
everything anyways and so um
we got back on the birds on the scooters
and then i was like you guys like wait
for me wait for me because i was still
kind of um unlocking the bird and bobby
was like see ya so he had already like
gone and then george you followed
because you're an [ __ ] too i guess oh
i gotta like keep the dust like be the
person in between
and gilbert said this to me he goes
i now know um the things like watching
you and bobby i now know why cindy gets
mad at me for the things that i do
you know that's awe that's you know what
you know what gilbert
you know what man
you know what man yeah
you know you don't know because you you
you don't just realize i'm a reflection
of you
no
no
if your final form i'm like
seven like i don't like go see i go
uh leave me alone
no i and i bird away had a half speed
than you yeah
he was able to realize through
me being left behind that he leaves
cindy behind often no no
let me ask you guys something okay yeah
when you're doing a marathon
okay yes
i've tried to picture myself when you're
on a marathon right do you jog or run
you do either one right
right you do either one right i pick one
speed right
walk is fine what you were doing with
the scooter was crawl
if if you if you saw the boston marathon
and you saw some guy from the starting
lineup just get on his hands and knees
and start crawling you would think that
this is a little weird hey terrible joke
but she wouldn't have died
yeah what
she wouldn't have died at the boston
marathon oh wait
wait wait so what you're saying what
you're saying to me is this right i
would have made it because i would have
you would have gotten to the left and
because that's where the bomb went off
yeah and she's still like halfway over
there and george and i would have no
legs right now we would all be dead
kalyla is like
yeah yeah i don't know that's an
interesting theory
maybe the marathon wasn't a good analogy
that might have been too dark sorry it's
a little dark like the the famous fable
the rabbit and the the turtles
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
ah guys um
you know if you're an online you have an
online business yeah and you need your
merchandise getting out there
ship station is the only place to be
it's what we use yeah if you run an
e-commerce business you probably feel